foreign we're taking a closer look at a
new policy that allows stores to sell
hearing aids over the counter the
government estimates almost 29 million
Americans have hearing loss that could
be helped by hearing aids but only one
in five actually use them why the big
issue is cost they're quite expensive
and over-the-counter hearing aids are
much cheaper CBS News medical
contributor Dr David agus joins us now
to discuss Dr akus good to see you like
you this is a big big deal so take us
inside where do you go to get it and big
question is it covered by insurance
so most insurance companies don't cover
hearing aids and you know it's very
expensive thousands of dollars and you
have to get an audiologist test Etc well
now you can get the tests you can do
there are apps that you can download and
look at your hearing and then go to
right now many large stores carry these
over-the-counter hearing aids and you
get them and you can adjust them with
your phone and make them personal for
you as we just said eighty percent of
people with significant hearing loss are
not getting these hearing aids so
obviously something was wrong and this
is hopefully we'll fix it
so what's the difference between getting
it over the counter and the more when
you when you say thousands of dollars
what does that mean exactly and how much
does it how much does it cost getting it
over the counter
you're always about the details Gail
um you know right now over-the-counters
cost anywhere from 200 to a thousand
dollars with the estimates from the
government are is you'll save about
three thousand dollars by getting these
over the counter versus getting them the
ones that are classically prescription
because the prescription also include
audiologists fitting adjusting all of
those functions what had to be included
and so it was very expensive and what's
exciting is you're getting new companies
coming to the space Sony just announced
that they're having one Bose is having
them and so you're really going to get
innovation in this space and hopefully
destigmatize it so that people say I
don't want to do it I will look weak if
I wear a hearing aid hopefully you'll
look cool if you wear a hearing aid and
we can get it because there are major
medical issues if your hearing goes down
okay and the quality is good too the
quality is just as good we should
emphasize that yeah Dr Aegis why is the
quality now why the Innovation why the
Innovation and also why this push for
the the lower cost option over the
counter
well in 2017 the the Act was passed and
then covet got in the way and so the FDA
announced it over the summer and now
it's been enacted which is great to
lower costs for the consumer there was a
lot of pushback from people saying
listen I can't afford hearing aids and
this is a way to lower the cost and
hopefully spur Innovation you know
people with hearing loss who don't have
hearing aids significantly more
depression isolation and medical issues
and we can give them a much improved
quality of life if we can improve their
hearing
Dr agus we know that hearing loss comes
with age but teens also struggle with
hearing loss as well how do you know
that you might need to go get checked or
go see a doctor
you know I mean nowadays teens are
putting in their air airpods and they're
listening to loud concerts and noises
and you know up to one of five teens
have hearing issues and so if you're in
a crowded place and it's very difficult
to understand conversations and others
can obviously get that test and again
nowadays you can download it on an app
and so it's been democratized everyone
has the ability now to do a hearing test
and see if they need it and I think
that's very powerful to enable better
social interactions and hopefully long
term a better quality of life
I think we're all good here no one has
started to scream to talk to us yet so
far so far so good so far so good Dr
David Akins thank you so much